hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to versus live presents binge battle hey
my name is Mark I had the host of the
show versus on Rotten Tomatoes where we
get to do things like Annabelle versus
chunky or Stallone versus Schwarzenegger
but today it's actually two of my dear
friends are going to step into the arena
and go against one another
my first competitor that's going to be
debating all things the office against
her opponent is the one the only you
know her from pertain we show on Rotten
Tomatoes the ketchup this has Perez is
in the building
what's going on guys is so excited for
this I can't wait to read everyone's
comments and how I honestly can't wait
to go up against you I mean it's gonna
be a jizz the trash talk is already
started I'm going up against a screen
junkies legend and tournament of nerds
co-creator and I can call him the cute
one
he is how Rudnick Oh mark come on takes
one to know one buddy
you know what nads before we enter this
virtual we're friends but now still
friends okay let's have I have one
question before we begin and that is for
you mr. Rudnick is that a cat that is
perched high on the Shelf er is that
some sort of decorative out what are we
looking at that in a love that supposed
to be some sort of like tactic defense
tactic
I think it's Artemis Fowl that's what
I'm gonna go with so Wow how amazing
which is kind of a disadvantage going
into it to Page ELLs internet connection
but we are gonna go into our first this
our first topic and again everybody who
is watching this live please be active
in the facebook chat and comment with
your pic and who you think Nazz are out
argued better for their various choices
and you're gonna be the one that
determines it at the end so you see the
scoreboard up there I'm just refereeing
this thing I have no say in the matter
all I am doing is watching my best
friends get bloody against one another
so
I'm gonna go to you first and then our
first topic here today is in terms of
the American office the best character
there's many different characters that
you get in the office and you can take
one of the leaves you could take like a
Michael Scott or you can take somebody
who showed up randomly in a couple
episodes but really let's an impression
on you so now as Perez the floor is
yours for a minute who is the best
character in the office all right guys
here we go
if you are watching the office and
Dwight Schrute is not your favorite
character I'm sorry you're watching the
wrong show the guy is the most hilarious
and had the greatest character art in
the entire show
carts off antisocial he's a nerd he
really hates Jim has a weird
relationship with Pam yeah he has a
weird relationship with Pam he takes all
the chip from Michaels and he's single
and in the finale he finds love he
marries Angela he makes Jim his best man
or his best man she tells Pam that she
is his best friend and he no longer
takes crap from Michael he's played by
the brilliantly hilarious Rainn Wilson
the man is untamed no one can be that
serious and funny at the same time his
superiority complex is the greatest he
has an ambiguous moral compass and to me
ladies and gentlemen that makes
incredible television you want to go
right you got to go with Dwight okay
just before I go to help Nass quick
follow-up question I have gotten in the
past that I look a little bit like Rainn
Wilson can you confirm or deny that
that's true okay so you like literally
like closed one eye and maybe like if I
woke up without my contacts on yes a
hundred percent you would be Rainn
Wilson let's go over to Hal Rudnick here
so pretty good argument from those Perez
how she is something for Dwight Schrute
who is your best character in the
history of the American office you're
really breaking up I don't know are you
or me we can certainly hear you how and
if this is some sort of a tactic to
garner sympathy
okay my great work and you
understand us because we can hear you so
I'm pretty clear sorry my uh that
everything was kind of freezing on my
end here so that's a great question
there are a lot of iconic characters
from the office but I have to go with a
character who stands undefeated when it
comes to funny lines hitting the bull's
eye hitting the target my guy is Creed
creed bratton
is the most iconic funniest character
the best character in the history of the
American office and I'll tell you not
only it's funny mysterious every time he
appears he improves the show but he is
one of the only original characters on
the American office if you look at
NASA's choice Dwight Schrute
he is patterned basically after Gareth
from the British office Michael Scott is
patterned after David Brent from the
British office you know Jim Pam they all
have their versions in the British Creed
is an original he might be one of the
only originals that doesn't have his
counterpart on the British office so for
being solely original for being the
funniest hands-down every time he
appears he's funny
Dwight's welcome gets worn out a little
bit sometimes I gotta go with my guy
Creed I just I love how both y'all
really showed up for this argument
because full disclosure my gateway into
the office which I've still not like
seeing all nine seasons up but my
gateway into the office was one of my
friends told me about creed bratton and
she's like what you've never you never
heard of Creed I was like no she showed
me this YouTube somebody compiled like
the best moments of creed on YouTube and
it's nine minutes long and it's just it
is jut busting fall down funny but is
created knowledge
all bangers wall-to-wall bangers here's
a couple the only difference between me
and a homeless man is this job I will do
whatever it takes to survive like I did
when I was a homeless man listen can I
rebuttal this for a sec you know if we
were going how with the most original
character sure you have an argument but
everyone watching right now if you want
to go with a potential murderer if you
want to support a potential murderer a
creep
sometimes pervert someone who mistakes
the smell of poop with soup then sure
have at it
the guy is barely in episodes and
whenever he has lines we don't even know
what the heck he's saying half the time
the first if you want argument outrun a
black pepper snake whoa Dwight Schrute
because we're voting for the best
character not most original and the best
ladies and gentlemen is Dwight you know
what he was I might have liked him a
little bit better from the British
office when his name was Gareth and you
are making my argument for me he is
weird
he is unpredictable this guy Creed
that's why we love him he is a wild card
every time he comes in he improves the
show with delicious lines the best lines
in the show hands down such as I've been
involved in a number of cults both as a
leader and a follower you have more fun
as a follower but you make more money as
a leader that is comedy getting true and
I love how sweaty we're getting just in
round number one so I'm hearing all
today now you called my bro reap is
actually sob that you're both wrong and
it's my wife's job roof s so I'm hearing
Michael Scott is the best but Michael
Stern unfortunately is not an option so
I need you all in the chat room to vote
do you think that it is Dwight or do you
think it's Creed so I have a couple
comments here on the Figueroa Junior
says Michael Scott is a living legend
the best spot ever but after Michael
left Dwight stole the show gonna say I
don't want it with everyone
Michel guys I obviously don't disagree
with you but the guy bailed on the show
and half of the world didn't even make
it to the final seasons so for that
reason I went with Dwight because he has
the full character art we just see his
evolution and he is I mean he's a sister
regional manager that's all I got to say
okay how we're getting some love for
creed too though because James Johnson
says Creed by a distance there's no real
backstory on him and he's this
mysterious old guy we never really get
to learn about he doesn't do too much
screentime but when he does he has
amazing and funny lines he's a he's a
brilliant sniper he shows up kills gets
out of there never overstays his welcome
unlike dwight schroot who overstayed his
welcome so long that his spin-off got
canned you know we all know too much
Creed we if you're not if you're not
pick and why you're watching the wrong
show okay well we do have a ruling we
have the audience score is in it has
arrived you both fought brilliantly in
round number one how I love creed
bratton
the audience is saying to whites true is
the winner Nazz gets the early one to
nothing jump on the scoreboard however
as we pivot to your second round I think
this is gonna be one that's right in
House ballpark why because it is his
word the most iconic moments in office
history so this is the most iconic thing
that you think has ever happened in the
nine seasons of the American office and
once again if you're watching us live
please both with what your most iconic
moment is and then between the two
participants in today's bench battle who
do you think is right how you're gonna
have a minute first what's the most
iconic moment yes well one of the
engines that drives the American office
is the will they won't they the
relationship between Jim and Pam and
that is a
essentially the heart of the show the
beating heart of the American office and
your gut you want something that
typifies that is the very essence of
that relationship and that is the roof
date that Jim and Pam have on season two
that date is the stuff of legend it's it
really brings together all the emotion
that has been just percolating up to
that point and when they're up there on
the roof in lawn chairs I mean you're
you melt your heart melts you you are
along for the ride and they that's how
they became America's Sweethearts you
know you could pick there are countless
funny moments but this is the heart of
the show and it is the most iconic
moment okay it's a good argument that
how presents now as now look I'm not
sure how you feel about this but I know
that watching the office in general
makes me a little uncomfortable because
my whole life is set up to avoid ever
being in an office and it's kind of the
same with dating is it if I see somebody
on first day I get nervous for them I
start breaking out in hives and sweating
so if there is a really gut-busting
moment that you have from the office
that you think is most iconic I might be
inclined to side with you what do you
got my first life so much to say about
house but I will save it for the
rebuttal so what iconic so when I think
iconic moment right I think Meryl Streep
when I think Meryl Streep I think of
Devil Wears Prada Day when Michael Scott
impersonates Miranda Priestly I'm just
kidding
okay so picking an iconic moment on the
office is actually so so hard but I had
to narrow it down to the pilot when Jim
hands Dwight his stapler and yellow
jello this moment symbolized the
contentious relationship between these
two characters that we were about to
meet at the end of the pilot Jim also
puts Michaels mug and jello but he does
it in private because he sort of
respects
Michael and I feel like this image of a
stapler and jello just stands the test
of time and really set up the three main
characters so perfectly if you start if
you opened a museum for the office next
to Angela's cat and a sign that says
that's what she said there would be a
stapler in yellow jello this moment
stands the test of time and is the image
of the office most iconic moment mic
drop
okay well captain you can with the
chilly has been voted on by Tay with
taste the Chili's a solid one so here's
the thing I would say Kevin with the
chili is absolutely Kevin with the chili
is absolutely funnier than the stapler
in the jello but it's not most iconic to
break through all of the clutter to
break through all of the laps and
everything you need something that is
funny but also poignant it touches us it
connects to our humanity
that's what iconic is iconic is
something that's transcendent it rises
above yes the office is wall-to-wall
funny if you if you wanted to make a
list of the best jokes and sight gags
you'd be here all day
not Nazz your choice would be on
somewhere in the middle of the list of
best sight gags but the most iconic
moment it's these two characters coming
together in is a precursor to what their
relationship I'm sorry how because your
moment wouldn't even be on the list
listen I'm a lover of love no one is
more of a hopeless romantic than I am
I'm gonna go on the record and say
something a little controversial right
now what Jim and Pam are kind of boring
Jim eats a ham and cheese sandwich every
day Pam draws I don't know tape
dispensers then Motel art and if I want
to take this argument even
further I do believe that Pam was
engaged to Roy at the time of this roof
moment so sure if you want to support
emotional infidelity go with house
moment but I'm sorry I just think jello
takes the jello instead of the cake in
this situation oh this is really cool I
mean your moment in your supporting
thievery and destruction of property I
would say which is the best character
ever because it was destruction or
property and that's why it was amazing
okay well we have a lot of fans siding
with both y'all so Caleb paste Holly I
want to get your take on Caleb's Tommy
because he says come on how Jim asking
Pam on their first date is more
impactful so why did you pick the second
date because the optics of this one
being on being on the roof the way they
connected though the way Pam got stood
up here and it led into her story about
being stood up in back in a high school
I believe there's so much that made this
date feel like the more iconic date
Eileen Rivera says that she's with you
but as Joel Mears is something for you
saying that it now is definitely on her
high school debate team is that true and
what would be your final work I was on
my high school debate team and my final
word would be Pam was engaged so sure
yeah support someone that emotionally is
cheating on someone else I just I got a
stand on on the site of of morality with
this one and I'm sorry that is just not
an iconic moment for me well the I would
actually can I make one last argument
how I think when when Jim and Pam kiss
at the end of the first dundies is more
iconic than that moment therefore making
my moment more iconic than yours well
that was a drunken moment between Jim
and Pam but this date on the roof this
is
she basically she was engaged okay
okay how you have the last word here we
go there there was no break in any kind
of there was no infidelity here but this
this lovely date laid the emotional
groundwork for what was basically the
heart of the show and if it wasn't
iconic how come you can find it on all
sorts of mugs t-shirts posters this is a
huge moment that really it I mean if you
love love you love this moment this is
where the kindling was was born of Jim
and Pam's relationship okay so this has
been by far the closest of the albeit
two categories we've done thus far mark
Hoffmeyer has a great quote that I agree
with these it's that the the jello
stapler is the best jello bit in media
since Jurassic Park and I would agree
with that
mom I'm looking at the audience score
and it is so very close but it does seem
like the audience is saying that the
second date while it was very romantic
was not iconic and that stapler in the
jello was more of an iconic moment to
get the office so unpredictably Nazz
goes up to - nothing
Oh Monica Rudnick Wow
I you know as as Joe Pesci said in the
shortest Oscars speech ever it is my
privilege thank you is that all he said
that's all he said it was the shortest
Oscar speech ever for Goodfellas oh he
was the shortest Oscar winner ever
I will yeah well as the short person
that's why I really great effect
feel free to fact-check that
okay while we fact check whether Joe
Pesci with Joe Pesci shorter than Anna
Paquin
how tall is Pesci we're gonna move on to
our third category but keep in mind if
al makes a rousing comeback and he ties
a nice tuna - we do have a backup
tiebreaker category just so you all know
maybe we get there maybe we don't but
we're definitely approaching category
number three and that is the best Jim
and Dwight prank of all time so we've
kind of already mentioned one of the
pranks and one of the many funny things
that happens daily in the office but now
we're moving into the best all-time Jim
the white prank
so now as you're already up to nothing
it feels like you're playing with house
money what would be your greatest Jim
delight Frank I first want to inform
everyone who so kindly joined us today
that Joe Pesci is 5'4 so when it come on
through the best Jim and Dwight prank
this was actually for me the hardest
thing of hit because there are so many
good ones I tend to go with I like the
pranks more that mess with Dwight's head
rather than inconvenience him like quad
does for example but I had to go with
identity theft when him dressed up as
Dwight and when I dressed up as Jim and
they impersonated each other this scene
is on the end not only is it hilarious
to see Dwight like them dress up at each
other but it gave us two of the greatest
lines from each character the first one
I actually have a little prop with me
here because I'm gonna do it the first
one just being bears beats Battlestar
Galactica and white correspond with the
greatest thing ever by saying identity
theft he's not a joke Jim it affects
millions of families every year and
because of those two lines alone it is
unbeaten and hands-down the greatest
Dwight Jim Frank in office history ok
how Nazz really going for the knockout
blow here with the glasses prop included
how do you combat with your best Jim
Dwight Frank okay so first off how does
the most how does a prank that was the
her most iconic moment not get chosen I
feel like she just contradicted herself
so if you want to take away her point
and award it to me I'll take it not
expecting it not expecting it but you
know the I feel like that her choice is
a little on the nose I would go for one
that was a little bit of a little bit of
a long game a little bit of a slow roll
where Jim got the best of Dwight he
reeled him in and that was the vampire
prank when it was a bat loose little by
little
Jim dropped these delicious clues that
made white start to believe that Jim was
a vampire the fact like it is such a
window into the city of Dwight the fact
that he can be convinced that a vampire
is real and Jim did it brilliantly
touching garlic bread and getting burned
the brightness of the crucifix in the
office little by little it added so much
not only that I think you got to bring
into the into the whole picture the fact
that there was a bat flapping around the
office and adds to the beauty of this
prank so I think all of the outside
stimuli the bat and the craziness going
on and then Dwight having the plot to
potentially defend himself from a
creature of the night I mean that is
that is far and away I feel like the
prank that Nazz described it's more of
like oh these guys were just kind of
taking the piss out of each other you
know no because they imitated each other
listen I have a prank I can appreciate
the vampire slayer' my man Dwight first
of all vampires are real Dwight has
killed a werewolf before after it turned
into his neighbor's dog and
it's a great prank I'm not I'm not even
gonna try and put it down and and Dwight
also had one of the greatest lines
during that Frank as well which is if a
human vampire were to showed up in the
United States it would be in a Sylvania
like Pennsylvania I've done it but I am
sorry how nothing in the world beats
bears Pete's Battlestar Galactica okay
so we're not we're not looking for the
best line we're looking for the best
prank
hey that's Sylvania line is brilliant
like we're making my case for me no
because seeing John Krasinski just get
the cadence of Dwight and just totally
embody that was something it's unbeaten
we've never seen it before
and honestly I'm sorry to rebuttal even
further your prank didn't even have much
of a payoff like Jim leaves the office
you know and he has his hood up and then
that said this one we get to see Dwight
sort of you know cut get back at him by
dressing up his hem so I felt like this
was more of like a full-fledged full
thought-out prank in other words yeah
you know that that just seems like you
know they're playing a you know dress-up
day
mine was a full prank Dwight had to go
online research vampires she had to form
an alliance with Creed my guy and ask
him if he's willing to take down a
creature of the night with him there is
so much happening also in the same
office you get one of the funniest
visuals of all time which is Dwight
capturing the bat in a garbage bag with
Meredith inside of it as well and he had
to get that back because he didn't want
to turn into a vampire and the vampire
seed was planted by Jim is lit on this
one because they're giving me so many
different iconic moments like Hasan said
that the Dwight snowball incident is one
of the greatest one yeah that one's
really good too so
gabriele brockner brings up an
interesting point saying that the
vampire prank is basically it goes the
whole episode whereas nas's your prank
is just kind of a cold open so maybe
maybe it's not because the white dresses
up his gym at the very end of the
episode if you watch the office so know
that is you know what I had already
turned it off right I already turned it
off by that point I missed it missed the
payoff whereas mine oh it's just
delightfully woven through the whole
thing top is top right there and because
because the audience is chiming in a sit
art gets the last word here in the
audience saying that Hal got this one
because identity theft is a great prank
but the vampire one is an Alzheimer and
underrated and most of the audience does
agree with sitar so ladies and gentlemen
how Grubnic is on the scoreboard winning
this room on the board and he got us up
on the board on the board Congrats how
you can have that one I still act ago it
was it was a great collection as with
bringing the glasses in but then I don't
know if you noticed when I was making
his final argument he kind of showed the
Robocop shirt that he's wearing and I
think I'll show my Robocop action figure
okay we're getting into what could be
the final debate of the day and that is
the best episode in office history like
I said nine glorious seasons or maybe
eight glorious seasons and then another
season depending on how they went off
the spin you are but there's so many
great episodes to choose from so I
simply asked what death episode of all
time how Rudnick you're on the clock
with your best episode okay
you know what I'm gonna get serious for
this one you know mark of all time if
this was very difficult you know I was I
was weighing a few I thought about the
dundies that was lit but you know what I
wanted to go early office because that
was when it was most raw and I thought
the writing was the best and I am going
the injury
episode Michael Scott gets injured and
it sets off just a brilliant chain of
events and this is key Michael Scott
he's insensitive tone-deaf and cloying
for attention and not only is his injury
stepping into a George Foreman grill one
of the greatest reasons that anyone
could get injured just that whole story
about he bugs him the George Foreman
grill to make bacon so we can wake up to
the sizzling smell of sound and smell of
sizzling bacon is bananas that is so
beautiful but you have it's like instead
of one entree just Michael Scott's
injury you have two entrees because you
have Dwight's concussion which plays
itself out brilliantly then the show
which also when it's at its best it
shows a little bit of heart in Michael
going in to be in the room for Dwight's
cat-scan and he puts his hand on
Dwight's leg while he's in there that's
like all kind of moment like that gonna
make you like fogged up a little bit
then like maybe you're not human
maybe go to like a mechanic because
you're a robot perhaps one more thing we
all know that Michael Scott is an
insensitive mf'er and says a lot of
things that might be deemed problematic
okay I said it the office can be really
fricken problematic sometimes this is
this might be this episode might have
the best takedown of Michael Scott
because if you're going to say
problematic crap you need to get smacked
down and a once in a while and when
Michael Scott is being so insensitive
about differently-abled people about
people with disabilities he brings in
the office
the site manager who's in a wheelchair
who in the middle of Michael Scott
trying to explain how like how bad his
injury is that the site manager who's in
the wheelchair shuts him down and leaves
BAM
what's the smack that and it is just
brilliant because you have Michael
Scott's insensitivity but then in one of
the rare moments he gets his comeuppance
and it was just beautiful to watch so
for so many reasons this is the funniest
the best episode so Wow how that's the
nose it's very Mike dong and and it was
amazing watching you look like a Lakers
fan but as soon as you put the moustache
on you look like a Chicago Bears the
Bulls kind of guy I meet you Lee after
that thank you
that now you look like me
miles Anthony Hoover says I Lakeway
cannot smell of bacon sue me so I think
that's at least one vote for how mad
look it was it was a long winding road
there are a lot of different reasons why
how is winning over the audience chat
right now how do you combat it what's
your best episode first of all how thank
you for that Nicholas Sparks version of
an answer I hope everything that went
after a minute gets disqualified because
I'm actually following the rules here
but I I'm sorry bro I mean I love the
injury my girl Mindy Kaling wrote it but
I gotta go with the first episode that
BJ Novak directed hands down Scott's
Todd's there is no competition there's
nothing more cringy and hilarious the
Michael Scott promising a group of high
school kids that he pay for their
college tuition 10 years prior because
he thought he'd be a millionaire by the
time that he graduates and when the bill
comes Stanley is just cracking up Pam as
you see Pam right now just saying the
inevitable that we're all thinking
Michael this is a terrible terrible
thing the longer you you make this go on
it's going to be so bad and it is just
an emotional ride the entire episode we
are just cringing on the end
at the edge of our couches waiting for
Michael to come clean he throws up to
the school he's joined by the brilliant
ellie kemper the kids have a song and
dance number that arguably is lit hey
mr. Scott what you're gonna do what
you're gonna do make our dreams come
true followed by a teacher thinking
Michael Scott for making us believe that
anything is possible
followed by a kid saying that he stayed
out of the drug game just because
Michael Scott and it is just I have
never been at the edge of my seat on the
couch with the fit with my entire fist
in my hand just waiting for Michael
Scott to come clean and he finally does
and tells them that you know he's gonna
give them lithium batteries and it is
just I think it's the emotional ride
it's the greatest payoff it's classic
Michael Scott I mean you know he's this
guy with the big heart he has
unrealistic promises but he's not in
touch with reality and I think if you
compare it to how's example we really
get to see real Michael Scott here if an
alien landed on earth and we had to
explain to the alien what the office is
all we would have to do is show them the
episode of Scott Scott because it is
classic office hands-down
hey mr. Scott what you gonna do what
you're gonna do make our dreams come
true you know that episode
it's very cringy but I found his
admission to everybody at all the kids
when he got up in front of a little bit
underwhelming and it did not have the
wall to wall bangers as far as laughs go
the injury is just banger after banger
Scott Scott's a fun plot device that I
don't think it quite lived up to there's
nothing funnier in that episode than
Dwight crashing it to a pole and then
vomiting on his car there is nothing
funnier in that episode then Michael
Scott talking about how he likes bacon
in the morning so he sets up a George
Foreman grill next to his bed
there is no funnier injury in all time
than stepping into a George Foreman
grill and then getting it wrapped with
bubble wrap and
he's walking around with a bubble wrap
on his foot and like people are just
like making fun of that all episode it
is wall-to-wall bangers yours is one
plot device that is done okay
one factor byte has done okay I couldn't
disagree more when Michael's fell under
his breath says I'm so so sorry it is
the greatest payoff I felt like I was on
a ride at Disney World and yes I will
say that him stepping on a George
Foreman grill is brilliant it is genius
no one is arguing that but it is not I'm
sorry it's just not better than Scott
stuck Scott's todd's is in a mohawk and
it is musical it's just look the best it
is when it does he get a second rebuttal
here one of the best things about the
carnage here because I've seen it out
one of the best things about the office
is when it gets edgy is when it dances
up to the line and I'll just go back
again and say when Michael Scott has the
unmitigated gall to compare his stepping
on a George Foreman grill to this man in
a wheelchair and saying we are the same
and be so tone deaf like we are like we
it's funny but cringy it's what we love
about the office but then in a brilliant
and like important moment for the office
Michael Scott gets smacked down because
I think there are a lot of these
automatic moments you have the last or
unchecked
sorry it's well you get to close this
out here now as he had 30 seconds to win
the argument I think all I'll say is how
there's nothing funny about a guy making
fun of a guy in a wheelchair
when I when I travel around the world I
see people with shirts on around the
globe in tour groups with shirts that
say Scots talks on it and no one is
wearing a shirt that says the injury on
it and that's all I gotta say
God's Tots is an international sensation
and I've always kind of had a disdain
for the George Foreman grill because my
roommates in college got one my junior
year and so for the entire year I
smelled nothing but that version of
cooked meat and like I still I think I
still kind of smell like that no amount
of Cologne so now I'm looking at the
audience chat and I think that this
brings up a great point about the office
in general and one of the reasons why I
was a little hesitant to watch the
office is because it is such a fine line
between being hysterical and being
cringy and I think both of these
episodes were talking about walk that
line so we have a couple fans weighing
in that I wanted to highlight Aaron
Fitzgerald says that Scott stocks is the
saddest episode of the office and Lucy
literally says she's gonna skip Scott
stocks I've also seen some people say
that Scott stocks is the best but as far
as the audience goes they are siding
with Hal Rudnick and we have ourselves a
good old-fashioned tie ball game going
into overtime
this is I don't know I'm questioning
everyone in the audience now that tends
to happen on the interwebs from time to
time once again everybody watching right
now I know I think we have well over a
thousand of y'all hanging out with us
thanks for tuning in and spend part of
your day with us we know it's a it's
it's got a rough times up there right
now we miss being around people in
person so we wanted to bring you all a
nice virtual debate right into your
living room and we're gonna settle the
score right now with a quick overtime
ground each competitor is going to get
in one minute to state their case and
then we're making a ruling so as soon as
y'all hear what you think you like the
best let us know and what the best is
gonna have to be in the overtime round
is the best Michael Scott quotes of all
time nine well again
eight seasons of Michael Scott this is
spewing period you see from his mouth
what is the best quote in Michael Scott
history Nash Perez you
we're gonna be kicking off with your
minute at your right well you gotta go
with that's what she said
you know we heard it in the pilot and it
was so perfectly said in the finale
nothing made me shed a tear more there
was not no more of a quotable line
everyone in the world said that's what
she said if you were fan of the office
and I feel like I don't even have to
have a great argument to this one aside
from the fact that it was it's just
classic Michael okay how that's that's I
mean you talk about going international
and seeing the office reference other
places I'm pretty sure people reference
the office without even knowing it when
they say that's what she said so what is
your bet Michael Scott quote so that
might be the most well known Michael
Scott quote but the best Michael Scott
quote that is the funniest and that
defines the man is I love inside jokes
I'd love to be a part of one someday
that is the best quote because it's
funny but it's so fricking sad he's the
clown that's not loved he wants to be a
part of it he wants to be celebrated by
everyone
he's so tone-deaf and doesn't realize
what and that he he knows his humor does
not connect that is it is so self-aware
and sad yes hilarious at the same time
because it's like he know not what he
say that is the perfect Michael Scott
quote for those reasons because it has
at heart and it has the funny okay I'm
being told I can I can get each one a
all quick 30 second rebuttal so now have
at it um how I really I actually love
the line that you picked and I think it
was like really sincere the way you just
delivered that argument so I really
appreciate it but honestly I feel like
there are way better lines than that
genuinely like
michael says I'm not superstitious but I
am a little stitches like there's a lot
more genius things that have come out of
Michael Scott's mouth and also embody
who Michael is but I I just I don't
think I need any we'll talk that's which
Nazz I agree with you that there are so
many funny lines to choose from but I
picked this because it's got the heart
it reveals it pulls the mask off and
it's so sad and funny it's got the
duality like the duality of man you got
your gyms you got your Dwight's you got
heart and you got comedy and pathos in
this line your line yes it's a line
that's been around for decades it's not
an original line and it was co-opted by
Michael Scott and it's became and it's
become synonymous okay but the best
quote that shows the man that shows the
sad clown that's I love inside jokes I
hope to be a part of one someday
oh that's all that we can ever hope for
in the comedy business how I'm looking
at the comments again it seems like it's
split right down the middle I'm seeing a
lot of great ones that I wanted to
highlight this show says that's what she
said is iconic and Debbie Day agrees
says that's what she said is the best
one then Caleb says Howland's because
it's the best suited to Michael Scott
quote of all time so if now I'm in the
unfortunate position I thought my job
was easy - gets really like watch y'all
now I have to actually deliver the news
to one of y'all that you lost so I'm
going to say that's what she said is not
going to be I win today because how
Rudnick has completed the greatest
combat in binge battle history and that
is coming back from a 2o deficit to win
3-2 - how the audience has made you the
winner today I hope your acceptance
speech is long
in Joe Pesci's you know what uh Naz you
took me to the soul you know the office
and I respect you I doubt my suppo to
you
I also doff my moustache to you
Nazz you're a truly knowledgeable great
fan of the office but I want you're the
best thing that happened in quarantine
since my wife making the delicious meal
the other day oh my god
IIIi want to thank I want to thank Jim
Halpert
I want to thank Pam I want to thank
Creed and everybody involved but mark
and everybody at Rotten Tomatoes thanks
for having me this was super fun and
thank you to the audience I hope
everybody staying safe out there and
practicing social distancing and let's
get through this y'all Wow Naza I don't
know if you saw that but that was like
we always criticize actors and actresses
when they win a big award and they get
political but that's exactly what Hal
just did I'll thanks everybody
and then he made a political statement
about making sure you stay serving so
maybe maybe those people in their ivory
towers don't have it so easy
I'm sure that you would also like have
new things to say to the audience and
everybody watch yeah I just want to
thank how I think how you had great
points you absolutely deserve to win
this was so much fun guys I'm just happy
to be a part of this and talk about the
office and that's what she said okay now
that we're all friends again before we
say goodnight I did want to let
everybody out there know that what we're
just like y'all because we're just kind
of sitting at home and we're working
when we can where we're trying to pay
the bills on time as best we are suited
to but we're also watching a lot of
stuff so I wanted to get Hallen asses
take on what you're bingeing right now
what your bins recommendation to the
audience is I'm only two episodes deep
of Tiger things I'm gonna finish that
and then I'm sur episode speak of Ozark
I'm really not good at benching so I'm
gonna eventually finish that season
three Nazz what is this show that you
need to tell all the folks up there to
watch and then come tell you about all
right so I got two for you guys I got an
oldie but goodie which is the
Sopranos and if you don't have HBO go or
HBO now HBO just released 500 hours of
free programming The Sopranos being one
of them and I gotta say god it's just so
good no matter how many times you watch
it and I feel like I'm turning into a
soprano like my mom calls me and tells
me about for the day and I turn into
Polly walnut and I'm like ma I got
enough problems all right I can't talk
to you now but in that i am i just
finished binging is called unorthodox on
netflix it's a limited series there's
only four episodes it's based on a
best-selling memoir of this woman who
grew up in the ultra Hasidic community
in Williamsburg Brooklyn
she Fellini's leaves her husband and her
entire life to go to Berlin Germany it
is extraordinary the cast is diverse the
acting is incredible it is so well done
Netflix even made an episode called the
making of unorthodox and it's a book so
we have all the time in the world I
highly highly recommend watching on
Orthodox female lead show which you guys
know that I love and it's a great story
on feminism and freedom alright so
unorthodox and the soprano so next time
and as gets to do the ketchup from the
studio she'll probably be wearing a
warm-up tracksuit how it is now your
turn
what are your bench picks for the
audience out there furry so it has on
those choices
Sopranos i watch that like it was over a
Christmas break he just decides he's
gonna have technical issues and party
late into the night I mean how we still
need you to be a professional to close
out the show just because he won doesn't
mean you're better than us can you guys
hear me here you go
you may now play DS and gentlemen now
running in a in a crazy reversal Maz
Perez gets the win because for Internet
hello
as we say good night here I am going to
speak for how and say everybody sing
live your TV particularly ESPN April
19th because the dollar
Chicago Bulls series is finally
premiering its earlier than it was
originally slated for for June that's
super exciting and then I also want to
give a shout out to everybody over at
shits Creek they just ended their epic
six season run it was such a beautiful
final episode and they had a great
behind-the-scenes documentary making
that season that they also aired so if
you can find it either streaming or on
demand somewhere definitely check out
all of shits Creek how it appears that
you're back with us
so I'm going to rest for I can't afford
you the win again and then let you close
out the show with your binging ooh thank
you
mark sorry for the technical
difficulties i really like nasa's pics
but on our two shows one i'm uh i'm a 3
so did I get caught up to it
these devs
Offerman plays an amazing character
who's like then of Mark Zuckerberg and
Jack from Twitter and like at the the oh
and Elon Musk he's like this
prototypical tech genius who is creating
this very mysterious technology and
there is murder
there's intrigues really piqued you like
ex machina really scratches that itch of
Technology and and Nick Offerman and the
cast is great and then I'm gonna
recommend a comedy this came out last
year I believe it's a sketch show on
Netflix called
I think you should leave and this
comedian Tim Robinson is freaking
brilliant and it's so uncomfortable and
so awkward yet hilarious even if you
haven't seen it you might have seen some
of the memes that have been expected
inspired by this show so I think you
should leave on Netflix it's one of the
funniest thing I've seen in the past few
years I have my homework cut out for the
week now and for everybody out there
watching you can just go to Rotten
Tomatoes calm and checked out the binge
central it gives you so many different
great breakdowns there's such a great
editorial staff around Tomatoes they
have all these different lists so you
can go check out like what the 150 best
Tom it needs to watch are the hundred
best sports movies or they have so many
cool random lists that you didn't even
think of making the list too they did it
for you to go check out binge central
over Rotten Tomatoes calm right now one
more time I want to get a huge shout out
thank you to both how run the end as
Perez follow them on all their various
social media platforms because the great
humans doing great work for not only
themselves in their own houses but the
community out there I know from
experience and I want to thank our tech
team for working so hard day and night
to get this show to you all so a big
round of applause everybody behind the
scenes and everybody out there watching
for all the audience and everybody here
Rotten Tomatoes thank you for spending a
little bit of your Florentine hopefully
we'll be back soon doing more fun show
such as this and until then my name is
Mark Ellis
and this has been versus live ninja
battle
[Music]